hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to Eve now we have a
Cody code that we need to put in here
it's it's a 9 plus 18 plus 4 which is a
31 we know nine times eight uh nine
times four nope
nine times it's green blue times red
sorry I'm terribly stupid green times
red nine times eighteen plus four that's
it okay sorry
I just was coordinating the numbers to
the colors though nine times 18 is 160
two plus four sorry I'm horrifically
stupid apparently 166 plus four one six
right
am i okay I got that sorry about that
I'm apparently bad at math okay an apple
on a tree sculpture taint wooden ample
okay what about that Apple born of a
tree that's usually how apples are born
but what does that mean why do I have an
apple now hey it's a doll on the ground
yeah so what
so uh so what about that what what does
that mean okay thank you very much for
that contribution to this conversation I
would like you to go after yourself in
the a okay how about I stay beware of
lips do you want an apple
you want an apple all right here we go
this is tasty I let you pass now go
through my mouth really really here go
through my mouth but beware of lips go
go go through all right oh you know you
know oh yeah that's nice thank you
it's a guillotine I played the
guillotine simulator on oculus rift
oh yeah wondering was thumbs gums we
happened I have my brain was going like
no so I'm not right here
it got different it got different it got
real different was that a pigeon blowing
a horn tooting out of fart breath or
that you know I like my description
better but we'll go with that one okay
fine
saving save go in the red door
oh hi you look a lot like that a blue
sculpture in the first area ah really ah
that's pretty much my description for
most of the things I see here pattern
you don't know this word ah ah ah ah ah
gonna be beatboxing boots and cats and
boots and cats and boots and cats heart
wound that painting was from the
original the lady in red I remember whoa
okay no how about no oh what the hell oh
no no what the hell how about no good
golly that was disturbing these lady in
red what the hell oh you're still there
oh you didn't go away smoking and what
is this oh no idiot oh oh oh you're oh
you're moderately creepy now now that
I'm out you cocaine ouch don't be so uh
don't be so weird all be so weird I'm
gonna
I'm gonna go through this door it's
locked
what am I supposed to do it's a friggin
Oh aah and there's a lady in red what do
i do what do i do what do i do beat is
this doing anything for you is this
doing anything you get Crampton dead
hello
oh no no no no no no no no how about no
no no no thank you
well thank you no thank you smoking huh
smoking heck oh there was all OH
this is key yeah oh oh I got a key
Oh got a key sweet all right
use the key I'm the greatest the woman
here nobody's home they'll always been
chase things until their satify woman
everywhere to the answer that one it's
what you what you know Pandora's on the
earth I'm don't know what that mean is
that the only book here where Tina has
filled with the various drawings by
quirt weena I wonder what this guy has
to do with all whoa having fun yeah
actually I am
I'm having fun don't know about this
little girl though but me yeah I'm doing
great okay
moving story but written drawn by xx xx
carry careless and the Galit did roll
the story drawn crayon okay ah what no
no no no no no no no no it crashed
bollocks
alright sorry about that I guess we
can't read that book that is that
delightful children's tale by the name
of gravity blah blah hi lady hey lady
how you doing you're looking good there
with your painting have you been working
out gosh you look fantastic
I know that crawling routine is um
definitely gets all the guys you know
it's gonna go now we go you oh whoa whoa
I'm gonna go flocked oh no don't tell me
I need to I don't want to read this
can't one of the books is just jutting
out what about this what she did
hahaha yes okay oh man I thought I was
gonna have to read that book and I
thought I wasn't gonna be able to
progress which would have been very
upsetting for me because I really like
this game so far and I don't want to do
it place rose you got it
Rose returned hell oh yeah okay so
moving on enough of the insanity let's
get some sanity when the Rose so too
will you I'm guessing die is kind of the
idea no water in the vows you and the
roser know the weight of your own life
okay what's with the blue petals with
the blue petals blood petals lady in
blue there is no lady in blue well well
well that is strange because it was a
lady in red and she came out of the
painting but she also had a statue of
herself in that main lobby area and then
it says something boy
hi uh hi art
uh he's holding tithing onto a key yeah
let's go take it from him
oh nothing happened he's in pain massage
his shoulders good idea to stop yeah
yeah he's in a lot of pain so he didn't
like my shoulder massage yay well then
he can just lay there and oh okay hello
hello a headless statue am I gonna have
to cut off that guy's head and I'm
painting tongue keeps wiggling alrighty
then
it hurts he's in a lot of pain would you
like a rose I don't know how do I have
an inventory of some sort I don't know
if I do I don't think I do
you're kind of bone dude so I'm gonna go
unless you're a lady I can't quite tell
maybe I could give this to the guy
yeah maybe wait hang on let me get no
that's not right either
you're uh ah wait a minute whoa whoa
whoa whoa wait no yeah that's right I
have a key
where can the key be used where can this
key be oh oh uh there was a door right
over here that was locked
I'm such an a-hole there we go gah
hi lady are you gonna be like your lady
in red what's under the cloth uh Oh yep
you're gonna be psycho
why what is there something on the
ground up there looks like a rose okay
how do I uh how do I get it II II hey I
got a gonna fake you out oh wow how it
hurt yeah yeah there we go all right got
it
yeah yeah oh hi laughs haha that's yes
yes huh don't do that don't do that
don't do that place the bling rose and
then place my rose and now I got the
blue rose to give to the guy or lady guy
have a balloon rose Oh what's this the
pains gone
ah eek
what is it now there's nothing left for
you to take I tell you we'll wait dear
me could you be someone from the gallery
so you are
oh thanks heavens thanks heavens there's
someone here besides me so I see you
don't have any clue how things got to
this point either it would seem we wound
up very similar situations I have to say
even down to these roses wounds appear
on me when my Rose loses its petals I
thought I was a goner there thank you
for getting it back now first things
first we'd better find a way out I think
I'll go mad if I stay in this dreadful
place for too long
I still haven't asked your name my that
was rude of me my name is Gary and you
are Eve Eve you say I can't very well
leave a girl to wander into danger no no
so I'll go with you okay
now let's go Eve are you gee what a
manly thing to say I was just a bit
startled really that was all it was
anyway let's keep going to watch out for
such bizarre things like that oh yeah
you're a manly man you just filled with
muscles and testosterone I can tell so
what do we do about this thing
what a lousy piece place for this thing
stepping back of the dad I'm heave thank
you you're so big and strong oh my
goodness you're so strong I don't think
I'm very old so it shouldn't be hello
grieving brides left-hand grieving
Brides right-hand yeah that's normal
dad's perfectly normal grieving bride
grieving groom okay I guess the grieving
grooms hands are a bit busy if you know
what I mean
hahaha okay now things are all grey okay
yeah what is that gross is that gross is
what why are there eyes on the floor
good question
I want a say v-point oh we got headless
statues patrolling the hallways no no
thank you
I know that would rather not okay I'm
gonna save here and then that's gonna be
the end of this part did something just
happen
I don't either way I don't know so
anyway thank you all so much for
watching click the annotation for more
videos that I've done and as always I
will see you in the next video
Ashley's updated
ah fu what what hell is